mr. Carling I have the co-captain is the
Khan right standard rudder zero seven
nine why center rather to zero seven
nine aye-aye sir
all islets wait till your stations
immediately we had enemy contact there
in zero eight seven
just imagine anyway a sheep would try to
escape a pack of wolves and you've got a
ship trying to get away from the Nazi
submarines that was the game of the
Battle of the Atlantic a wolf pack's yet
on us they'll attack as a group yeah
waiting for nightfall Greyhound is about
an American destroyer escorting a convoy
of merchant vessels that's crossing the
Atlantic to bring vital war materiel and
soldiers to our alumns captain Krause
has been given quite a lot of
responsibility as a first-time commander
it's a bit of a trial by fire
the Nazis had submarines u-boats and
their job was to sink any allied ship
that was floating at sea that dead
silence and just waiting to see what's
on your radar screen you can imagine
almost a fella and under the time we're
nowhere near air cover we're low on fuel
no one has any idea if they are going to
make
what do you did yes but I got us two
today it's not enough charlie not nearly
enough Kraus has a lot of pressure on
himself because he has a lot of lives at
his hands in every decision he makes
determines the outcome of the whole crew
I don't think there's any commander that
doesn't have this innate fear of being
wrong but that has to be conquered you
cannot let your command me governed by
this nagging doubt of what if I am wrong
there they come
full speed ahead ladies recollection
[Music]
you